I mentioned at the top of the show today
that part of Donald Trump's worst day
yet in his presidency yesterday October
30th 2017 includes the shutting down of
Donald Trump's trans jets transgender
military band we have a federal court
now saying no you're not going to just
enact the transgender military ban and
kick out and enforce the discharge of
transgender military members over the
summer Donald Trump announced you might
remember first on Twitter that he was
going to be banning all transgender
people from the military and we've now
heard from US District Judge Colleen
Collard Catelli a lot of alliteration
there Colleen caller Catelli who wrote
yesterday that transgender members of
the military have sued over the change
that was likely to take place and that
they are likely to win their lawsuits so
she has said to the Trump administration
you cannot enforce the transgender ban
for the time being this is a preliminary
injunction it's not a decision about the
ban itself right what what Colleen would
judge Colleen as I call her is saying
here is that while I am NOT deciding the
merits of the ban there is a lawsuit
that has a good chance of succeeding in
stopping the ban and thus we are not
going to start the discharging of
transgender military servicemembers at
this time and once again like with the
travel ban Trump completely self
sabotages remember with the travel ban
where the court decision I think it was
travel ban 1.0 maybe it was 2.0 one of
the court decisions saying you're not
doing the ban we're stopping the ban for
the time being said that it's not just
what is written in the policy and the
executive order issued by Trump the
statements he is made about the intended
effect outside of the executive order
also make a difference basically saying
what Trump said on to on Twitter and at
campaign rallies can be considered in
terms of considering the legality of the
ban and we can look at once again the
statement made here in the decision with
this with regard to Jane Doe at all
versus Donald Trump at all that once
again Trump statements out
I'd of the actual executive order and
directive are a problem the Court finds
that a number of factors including the
sheer breadth of the exclusion ordered
by the directives the unusual
circumstances surrounding the
president's announcement of them the
fact that the reasons given for them do
not appear to be supported by any facts
and the recent rejection of those
reasons by the military itself strongly
suggests that plaintiffs fist Fifth
Amendment claim is meritorious I like
that the unusual circumstances of how it
was communicated by Donald Trump that he
would be banning transgender military
service members from serving in the
military that refers to the hairbrained
tweets that went out before Donald Trump
actually worked with the Pentagon on
what the policy change would be and
you'll remember that the Pentagon itself
was sort of shocked they didn't know
that Trump was set to announce this so
again a preliminary injunction one done
on the basis of pending legislation the
Trump administration could appeal it we
don't yet know if the Trump
administration is going to peel it but
the bottom line and I've said it before
and it's not changed by this is that
this is a silly policy it's a pointless
policy it will likely be Trump cited the
costs of medical treatment for
transgender military servicemembers as
part of the reason for this ban we have
learned that it will likely be more
expensive to implement the ban than the
actual cost of transgender related
medical service to the small portion of
service members that are transgender and
supposedly we have a shortage in some
parts of the military Trump signed an
executive order last week or the week
before saying that hey we are going to
start recalling or at least give
ourselves the option to recall retired
pilots to active duty because we might
need them and if you have on the one
hand a shortage in some areas of the
military why would you be suggesting an
expensive policy to find and get rid of
every transgender service member who has
volunteered to serve and this is yet
another piece of what is very quickly
becoming the most aggressively pathetic
and sort of most damaging is not even
the right word it's sort of like an M
since first nine months by Trump where
he's accomplished almost nothing he's
been trying to ride the rise in the
stock market as his big success and even
there we have indications that that's a
bubble that's going to pop at some point
in the next six to 18 months no
accomplishments to speak of I was
against the transgender military ban i'm
glad that it's been blocked but from the
point of view of donald trump and
putting something on the wall as
accomplishments yet another failure the
video you just watched was made possible
by support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad